We're going to use these prime factorizations to find the greatest common factor
for 216 and 192. The greatest common factor for these two terms, is the product
of the lowest power of each of the factors that appears in each term. For
example, if we looked at 12, and 44, we could see that they both share a two to
the second power. They don't share a power of three, and they don't share a
power of 11. So two squared, or four, would be the greatest common factor for 12
and 44. So what do you think is the greatest common factor for these two
numbers? Write your answer in this box. You'll also want to simplify your
answer. For example, if you think two cubed times five is the greatest common
factor, you would really write that as 40, since two cubed is eight, and eight
times five is 40.